>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Carlos Lozada: It is my great
pleasure to give you Nathan Hill.
[ Applause ]
>> Nathan Hill: Thank you.
Wow. Thank you for coming.
I wrote this book for a long time.
It took me 10 years
to write this book,
and there were moments along the way
when I would kind of
daydream, you know.
I would allow myself to
think, "What would it be
like to have a book
out in the world?"
What would it be like to
be a published author?
And I would entertain
all of these thoughts,
but there are certain things
you can't prepare for.
For example, last night I was
standing at the Library of Congress
at this festival's opening
gala which was lit up in purple
like a rave in Paisley Park,
and today I'm in front
of you good people.
And this is just not something
I ever expected to do.
So thank you so much for coming out.
I really, really appreciate it.
One of the things I did
daydream about -- I'm sorry.
I just have to tell this story.
One of the things I did daydream
about when I was writing this book
was like, "Well, wouldn't it be cool
if one day I saw my
book out in the wild?"
You know, like somebody
out there reading it.
Like at a restaurant
or a cafe or an airport
or on the train or something.
So chalk this story up to be
careful what you wish for.
On the trip that I took just before
this one I was flying from Boston
to Seattle, and I sat down
in my seat on my plane next
to the two most talkative people
on the airplane, just super chatty.
I don't know about you.
I usually kind of put on
my headphones and just try
to like just ignore everything,
but that was impossible.
And they were so friendly,
and you know they sussed
out very quickly who I was.
"Oh, you're a writer.
Oh, really.
What are you doing in Seattle?
You have a book out.
What's the book called?"
Etcetera, etcetera.
And the guy next to me was like,
"I'm going to buy it right now."
I'm like, "Okay."
So he pulls out his phone
and he gets in to the app
and he buys the book, and then it
downloads right before we have to --
Like right before we have to put it
on airplane mode and we take off.
And so he's reading the --
He's sitting right next to me.
And he starts reading my book,
and he reads the prologue
which is just like
a page and a half.
He reads the prologue,
and he turns to me.
He's like, "All right.
Not bad." And I'm like, "Thanks."
Thinking, okay, he'll put the book
away and he'll go on with his life.
But no. Then he moves
on to chapter one,
and he starts reading chapter one.
And it's clear that he is just going
to keep reading while I'm
sitting right next to him.
And so I'm like, "This is awful."
Because like if he laughs of
course I'll look over and be like,
"What is he laughing at?"
Or if he doesn't laugh, that
sends a completely different
signal altogether.
And so I'm like, "I have to
signal to this guy that it's okay
for him to stop reading."
Because maybe he hates it,
but he then can't put it away
because I'm his neighbor now.
So I act like I take a nap.
Like for a half an hour
I act like I take a nap.
And then I kind of open my
eyes and he's still reading.
And so then I put on a movie,
and I watch the whole movie.
And I look over, and
he's still reading.
He's reading completely
expressionless the entire flight.
And so we land and he looks
over at me for the first time.
He speaks and he says, "Good job.
Good job."
And I said thanks.
And he said, "You know, a couple
of times there I almost
laughed out loud."
And his wife leans over
and she's like, "Oh,
that's really a high compliment.
He never laughs out loud."
And so I was like, "Maybe
this is a special occasion."
Like we should commemorate this.
This is pretty weird, right?
So I'm like, "So do you want to
like take a selfie or something?"
And he's like, "No.
Why would I do that?"
And he went "Bye."
And then he walks away, and that
was -- I never even got his name.
So be careful what you wish for.
Finally the only other
story I want to tell you
about before I start talking
about the book is something
that I never daydreamed about
that I discovered recently.
There is right now for sale
on Amazon an ebook called
"Summary of the Nix."
I don't know if you know.
Like when I was in high school
it was called Cliff's Notes.
I think they're called Spark Notes
now, but I discovered this recently
that somebody had done
this to "The Nix."
Somebody had written a 44
page summary of "The Nix."
And I'm like, "It's not
like my book is being
like assigned to high schoolers."
Like why would anybody
buy a summary of the book?
And there are user reviews.
There are comments.
And I'm going to read you a couple.
"This summary of the
Nix was well written.
I could read the summary
again and again rather
than the whole novel itself."
"I sometimes have a difficult
time finishing a book
because I can't read
it all at one sitting.
With this summary, I
don't have that problem."
"This summary makes it
possible for the reader
to have a cocktail
party talk recognition
of all the ideas presented
by a new author."
And that was the one when I
knew I'd made it, you know.
When like people, like strangers, at
cocktail parties feel like they need
to have read my book, but
don't actually want to read it.
That made me feel really special.
Anyway, thank you everybody
for coming.
Thank you, Carlos, for the
really wonderful introduction.
I always feel bad for people
who have to introduce me
because then they have the burden
of describing what the book is
about which it turns out
is kind of a challenge.
I had to do this for the
first time last summer
at the BookExpo American
conference which was the beginning
of the whole kind of
run up to publication.
I'd never really thought
about it before.
You'd think that I wrote
the thing so I would be able
to describe it well, but that
is totally not true at all.
I was actually scolded by
a member of the sales team
for being so bad at this.
I was at a restaurant
and she said, "All right.
Pitch me your book.
What's your book about?
Pretend I'm a stranger.
What's the book about?"
And I was like, "Oh, all right.
Well, it's a -- It's sort of like
political protest and video games,
but it's not really
about video games,
and it's also there's some
academic satire in there
and there's a mother son story.
And the first half of the
book is sort of about the son,
but the second half of the
book is sort of about the mom.
And if I guess I had to sum
it up, I'd guess it's kind
of just about life, you know."
And this woman whose job it is to
be good at this, she looks at me
with these like daggers of living
hatred and she's like, "No.
Try again."
You know? This is not something
they teach you about in school.
They teach you how to maybe write a
book, but they don't teach you how
to talk about the book
without being a total bore.
So it's difficult describing
this book.
My hometown newspaper
called it just, quote,
the "Book about everything."
And left it at that.
My favorite quote came from
"Entertainment Weekly."
And this is how they put it.
"If any novel defied an elevator
pitch in 2016, it was 'The Nix.'
As a critique of millennial
entitlement, video game addiction,
and clueless academia, tender
meditation on childhood friendship,
first loves, and maternal
abandonment, handy tutorial
on '60s radicalism and
Norwegian ghost mythology,
Nathan Hill's overstuffed debut
contains multitudes and then some."
Which I'd say that
was pretty accurate.
The truth is I didn't know I
was supposed to write a book
that could be neatly summarized or
elevator pitched when I was writing.
All I wanted to do was write
a book that felt to me true,
that felt like it accurately
represented what the world felt
like on my nerve endings.
Now I'm not a writer who
creates an elaborate plot
or an outline and hammers
away at it.
For me it's much more about
creating a certain feeling,
a certain emotional timber.
And the plot usually
comes as a result of that.
When I sit down to write
in the morning I don't quite know
what's going to happen that day,
but I know how I want it to feel.
And that's a starting place.
So I end up constructing my plots
just a little bit at a time,
going where the emotion
is and having no real idea
where I'm going to end up.
There's this quote from
E.L. Doctorow that I love
about this kind of writing.
He says that writing a novel
is like driving a car at night.
You can only see as
far as your headlights,
but you can make the
whole trip that way.
And that's what writing
"The Nix" felt like.
That I can only see
so far in front of me,
and a lot of times you're
kind of operating on your gut.
You have an impulse to add
something, and then you try it out,
and then sometimes it
feels right and it stays.
So I wanted to tell you a
few stories about how some
of the major subjects covered in
the novel got there, and want to try
to answer a question that I've
been getting a lot in the last year
which is, "Why did you write
a book about so many things?"
So the primary topic
of the book is protest.
The novel covers two or maybe even
three generations of protesters.
You have the protest of the 2004
Republican National Convention
in Manhattan, the 1968 protest of
the Democratic National Convention
in Chicago, and there's a
little Occupy Wall Street
in there in one chapter.
This all happened because I
started writing this book in 2006.
I'd just finished school and
I was moving to New York City.
And now this was something
I'd wanted to do
for a very, very long time.
I was a kid who grew up in the
Midwest with like big dreams
of like going to New York city
and becoming like I don't know,
like Truman Capote or something.
You know? Like I wanted
to get invited to the cool
"Paris Review" parties and so forth.
And so this was where I was going
to end up for most of my life.
I kind of knew this.
I even -- I grew up in the Midwest,
and started rooting for the Yankees.
Like that's how committed I was.
Yeah. I know.
I know. And so I finally
moved to New York in 2006.
I was like 26 or so.
And it felt like a kind of
dream come true, you know.
It was what I'd been waiting to
do for a very, very long time.
And my first month
in the city I lived
in a sublet while I was looking
for a more permanent apartment.
I rented this one month
sublet in Queens.
And it was -- I was like sharing
a house with 12 other guys
who all worked in the same
road construction crew.
And they would come home at the
end of their shifts and like change
in to their underwear and eat hot
dogs and just play enormous amounts
of "Call of Duty" in the living
room like for the rest of the day.
This was life, you know.
The guy I was renting the room from
turns out was like this fanatic
for B horror movies, and so like
every square inch of the wall
in his bedroom was covered with like
pictures of people like screaming
or bleeding or both, you know.
So it was weird place to live
my first month in the city.
And so I didn't spend
much time there.
I was kind of out and about in the
city seeing what was happening.
And one of the things that
happened my first month in the city,
this was August 2004,
sorry, August 2004,
was that the republican presidential
nominated convention was being held
in Madison Square Garden.
And this was of course
Bush/Cheney second term,
and the war in Iraq was ongoing.
And so a lot of people were
coming in to town to protest,
and so I thought this was going to
be a really uniquely New York thing
to watch so I will go see it.
And I did.
Anyway, fast forward to
the end of the month.
I have found a new apartment,
but there's this awkward day
where I have to be out of my sublet
in the morning, but I can't move
in to my new apartment
until the evening.
So I put everything in my car.
I go to work.
I come back, ready to move in to my
new apartment, and the car is empty.
Like everything's gone.
So all of my books,
all of my clothes,
and most importantly the computer
on which I had stored everything I
had written in my graduate program.
Like three years of
writing, a book in progress,
all of it was just
gone all of a sudden.
And you ask me, "Did
you back it up?"
And I would say, "Yes.
I back it up on CDs that were
stored stupidly right next
to the computer."
So they were stolen too.
As a side note to this story, I
then sent out hundreds of fliers
to the area pawn shops saying like,
"If you see this computer, call me.
I will buy it, no questions asked."
And like a day later I got a phone
call from a guy who ran a pawn shop.
He's like, "Are you the
guy with the computer?"
I said, "Yes."
My heart was singing, "Yes.
I'm the guy with the computer."
He says, "Yeah.
You're never going
to see that again."
I was like, "Why?"
He's like, "It's too old.
Nobody would buy it.
Check the dumpsters."
I'm like, "Oh, god."
You know? So it was like just
twisting it a little bit.
And so I had no writing.
I had nothing.
So I had to start over.
And so I kind of couldn't bear it.
It was just too heartbreaking to
like continue working on the thing
that I'd already been working on.
It was just too filled with
negative emotion for me
to like be -- to work on it.
So I was like, "I'm just
going to start something new."
And so I decided to write about
the thing that was most interesting
that I'd seen recently
which was the protest
at the republican nominating
convention.
And I didn't know it at
the time, but that ended
up being the first words
I wrote for "The Nix."
It was about these protests.
And one of the things
that one of the --
Like the talking head cable news
type folks were saying at the time,
they were asking if the protests in
2004 were going to get as violent
as the protests in Chicago in 1968.
And I was really dumb.
I was like, "What happened
in Chicago in 1968?"
I had no idea.
I'd lived in Chicago.
I spent lots of time there.
I had no idea what had happened.
I was very naive.
So I looked it up, and I saw that
there was this amazing history
that I was completely unaware of.
And the more I looked in to it,
comparing these two protests,
'68 and 2004, the more it just
something about it hooked me.
I realized that I was
looking at something
that felt sort of familiar.
One journalist in 1968 in Chicago
described it as the tectonic plates
in American political life grinding
against each other
on Michigan Avenue.
And in some ways that felt like
-- That felt very familiar.
Even in 2004, it felt like the
world was getting much more --
The political life of the country
was getting much more polarized.
I noticed that conversations
between people in different ends
of the political spectrum
were getting more strained
and more strained.
And so it felt relevant.
I didn't know quite what
I wanted to say about it.
I didn't know quite how
it would turn into a plot,
but it felt like it burned
for me for some reason.
And there -- Two studies
came out recently.
I didn't know this at the
time, but two studies came
out recently about
this very subject.
And in one there's a
survey done in 1960
that asked American adults
whether it would disturb them
if their child married a member
of the other political party,
if it would disturb them.
And in 1960 no more than 5%
said yes in either party.
In 2010 they asked that question.
That question was asked again, and
this time 33% of democrats and 40%
of republicans said yes,
it would disturb them
if their child married someone
from the other political party.
And that was a bigger
number than nationality,
than religion, than race.
That partyism ended up being kind
of the line that people drew.
And a more recent study showed
that they've been doing a survey
of college freshmen every
year for many, many years,
and one of the questions
they asked is about,
you know, their political views.
And this year's incoming
freshman class is --
shows the fewest number
of political moderates
that we've seen since 1968.
So every time I would kind
of look in to this more,
it just felt like there
were certain symmetries
between the political
moment I was living
through from 2004 to
the present and 1968.
It just felt important to me.
So I put it in to the book.
I didn't know quite what
was going to happen with it,
but I put it in to the book.
The other thing on a separate like
parallel track from all of this,
I started playing video games.
You would think that those
wouldn't relate at all,
but after all of my stuff was stolen
in New York and I was quite sad,
and things weren't quite
going very well at the time,
I was doing very little writing.
I was sort of broke.
I was working at a
nonprofit poetry organization.
So you can imagine what
my salary was, you know.
And so a friend of
mine, he called me.
He says, "I want you
to buy this video game.
We're going to play it together."
And I said, "What's the game?"
He said, "It's called
'World of Warcraft.'"
And I was like, "What's that?"
I'd never heard of it.
He's like, "Just trust me.
Just buy it."
So I'm like, "Okay."
So I bought it.
And we played, and he has since
told me that the only reason he did
that was because you can chat with
the other person that you're playing
with other -- You know, on the game.
And so he just wanted
to keep an eye on me.
He's a very good friend.
He's very sweet.
He just wanted to make
sure I was okay.
So we played the game every
night, and we would talk.
And this went on for about six
to eight months before he
finally got sick of it.
He's like, "No.
I can't play this anymore."
And so he quit, but
I just kept going.
Like I had never really been
a gamer before in my life.
Like I donated one summer when
I was maybe in fourth grade
to beating "The Legend of Zelda."
And other than that I've
never really played.
But I played just the crap
out of "World of Warcraft."
And if you don't know anything about
it, it's really embarrassing for me
to talk about it now, but if you
don't know anything about it,
it's like imagine like "Lord of
the Rings," you know, like elves
and dragons and that kind of
stuff, but with like millions
of people playing simultaneously.
And I played it so much that
even after I left New York
after a couple years I kept playing,
and I would like cancel social
engagements because I had
to go raid with my guild, you know.
And I got really good at
it, really good at it.
And it's a complicated game,
and when you get really good
at it you feel good about that.
And I don't think I would
describe it at the time this way,
but now I do which is that it was
in some ways emotionally analgesic.
It was kind of it was
my painkiller, you know.
Like nothing else was going very
well, but at least I could come home
at the end of the day and fire
up this thing and get on board
with a bunch of other people
who we all respected each other
for being good at this thing.
And it was really important
to be good at this thing
when everything else
was going poorly.
And it was also an effective
distraction from kind
of the real world for
a little while.
But then fast forward
three or four years
and I realized I absolutely
could not be distracted
from the real world anymore,
spending way too much time
in this digital world, and so I
had to abandon it and I quit kind
of cold turkey and
haven't played since.
But there's something
about it, about that kind
of love/hate relationship
I had with the game.
I appreciated how it helped me get
through a dark time in my life,
but at the same time I really like
resented that it took so much time.
And also I had to like admit to
my friends I was doing something
that 12 year olds also do.
You know? So -- And so this kind
of love/hate ambivalent thing,
I felt like it was good.
It was good fodder
to treat in fiction.
I'd never seen fiction do
this to a video game before.
So I'm like, "Well, why not try?"
So I threw it in to the book.
I didn't know how it
would be relevant,
but I put it in to the
book and I was like, "Well,
let's see if I can
connect this in some way."
At the same time, I leave New York.
I move to Florida.
I live in Naples, Florida which is
this cozy little beach community
on the Gulf of Mexico.
And I went there to teach.
I got a job teaching at
Florida Gulf Coast University.
And so for a long time -- I
did this for about 10 years.
For a long time I thought of myself
more as a teacher than a writer.
And I would -- You know, I kind
of threw myself in to teaching,
and I kept on having these
experiences with students
that were really shocking to me.
A good -- I'll tell
you two quick stories.
The first one was my
first semester teaching,
and I taught first year writing
classes, composition one.
And I go in to my first class
to teach and there's 25 students
in the room, and I teach
my class and I go home.
And I come back like two days
later for the second class
and of the 25 students,
21 still remain.
And this happens.
Like they shop around and
like take, you know --
drop and add and so forth.
And so of the four people
who dropped the class,
three of them eventually
their names fell off
of my online roll,
but one name stayed.
And I kept on waiting
for this name to leave.
I kept on waiting for her to drop
the class, and she just never did.
Eventually I just kind
of forgot about it.
And I taught my class, and
it's the end of the semester.
It's the last class
before finals week.
And I walk in to teach and
there's this new person
in the back of the room.
I was like, "Hi.
Who are you?"
And she says this name.
It's the name from the roll.
And she hasn't been there since day
one, and I'm like, "Welcome back."
You know? And I teach my class
and she comes up to me at the end
of class and she says, and this
is a quote, I swear to God.
She says, "So I think I've fallen
a little behind in your class.
What extra credit can I
do to get a good grade?"
Not to pass, but to
like get a good grade.
I was like, "There's
not enough extra credit.
Like you've missed
literally the entire semester.
Like you've missed every
single assignment."
And she's like, "Seriously?"
And she was really upset about this.
She's like, "You're
going to fail me?"
And I'm like, "Well, it's
not -- It wasn't my choice.
Like you just didn't
do any of the work."
And she's like, you know -- I
told her that the school had this
like really generous thing, policy,
like she just retakes
the class next semester
and whatever grade she
gets will replace the F.
And so it will not even be
on her transcript or her GPA.
No problem.
She's like she wasn't
satisfied with that,
and kind of leaves really angry.
And then like on a hunch like two
days later I check this website,
ratemyprofessors.com.
I don't know if you
know this website.
It's like Yelp for teachers.
It's terrible.
And sure enough there was a brand
new review of me posted anonymously
that said, "I asked this guy for
help and he refused to help me.
He's a jackass."
Like, oh, okay.
Welcome to teaching.
And the other story that kind
of -- that was sort of typical.
I had a student who
turned in a paper.
I discovered very quickly
that it was plagiarized.
It was like all copied and
pasted from this website.
And so I asked her to come to my
office, and she came to my office.
And I was like, "Listen.
Like this paper -- Here's your paper
and here's the website
where it came from.
Can you please explain this?"
And she looked at me and
she's like, "I don't know.
It's weird."
[ Laughter ]
I said, "What do you mean weird?"
She's like, "I don't know.
It's just weird."
I'm like, "Is it like
-- Is it a coincidence?
Like did you accidentally type
exactly what was on this website?"
She's like, "I don't know.
It's just weird, and
my dad's a lawyer."
Right. So yeah.
I -- And so I kept on having
these kinds of experiences.
I kept on -- And just
I couldn't figure
out like what is going
on with my students.
And I should say like most college
students are, you know, wonderful,
hard working people, but I had
enough of these types of experiences
and my colleagues in the
profession had enough of these types
of experiences that
it felt like a trend.
It felt like something
weird was going on.
And I couldn't quite figure it out.
And so I started writing about
it because again I tend to like
to write about something
that I'm confused about.
And so this character appeared in
the novel one day, Laura Pottsdam,
if you've read the book, and
she became the embodiment
of all of these students.
And then like you do -- Almost
like you do in real life,
you know, you meet someone.
You have a first impression of them.
And then you interrogate that
first impression over and over
and over again as you
get to know them.
And as I got to know Laura, as I got
to know my own real life students,
I began to realize what was maybe
going on which is that they --
They came to college in
a different environment
than I came to college in.
You know, they grew
up during a recession.
They grew up during
tight times, you know.
And they had been given
advice by, you know,
people that were well
meaning and loved them,
but maybe bad advice about, you
know, the purpose of college is just
to secure yourself a job.
It's a tight, you know,
brutal economy.
And so you don't have time for
things like writing and poetry.
Like go out and get something that's
just job training for something
that will pay you well
because it's a global economy
and you don't want
to be left behind.
And so they kind of came
to college thinking, "Okay.
I just need to get this slip
of paper and get out of here.
I need to get that credential."
And then they would meet people like
me who believe in like antique ideas
like a well rounded education.
You know? And we're just like
two discursive ships passing
in the night.
And so these kinds of interactions
seem sort of inevitable.
I know that they felt enormous
pressure to do well in college.
I know when I was in college
I just didn't work very hard
for a semester, and I
might get a C in a class.
I would just kind of take
it on the chin and move on.
You know, okay.
No big deal.
Pretty confident that I would
get a job when I graduated.
My students had no
such feeling, you know.
They could not get a C. Whether
it was between getting a C
or getting an A and cheating,
getting an A and cheating
was better.
You know? And they would
do it all the time.
And they were not guaranteed
a job out of college.
Most of them were just hoping for an
unpaid internship for a couple years
to try to get the experience
to get an actual job.
So it's a very, very different time.
And so my own, I don't
know -- It was --
Part of the problem was my own
kind of lack of empathy for them.
And hopefully that
shows up in Laura too.
So yeah. So I put it in the book.
I didn't know how it
connected to everything else,
but I put it in the book.
And the last thing I'll
talk about is the theme,
the kind of big primary theme of
the book, is maternal abandonment.
The main character, Faye, leaves
the other main character, Samuel,
her son, when he's 11 years old.
And he doesn't see her
again for about 20 years.
And this has led many, many people
to ask me about my own mother.
Like imagine like explaining
to like a reporter from the
"New York Times" like, "No.
My mom did not -- "
I've probably gone
on too long before mentioning this.
My mom has almost contractually
made me
at every public event
tell everybody, "No.
My mom has never abandoned
the family.
She's never abandoned anyone.
She's a very sweet,
loving, wonderful person
who likes the book a lot."
But she didn't know what I was
working on for the longest time.
And finally when the book
was bought, she's like,
"So what's your book about?"
And I said, "Um, well,
it's about a bad mother."
And there's this like
long pause on the phone.
She sighed.
She's like, "You know what
people are going to think."
I'm like, "I'm sorry."
So yeah. No.
My mom's wonderful.
But I was never abandoned, but
growing up we did move around a lot.
My dad was in retail.
And he took every promotion that was
offered to him from the, you know,
sales floor in sporting
goods to the sales floor
in some other department to,
you know, then assistant manager
to manager to regional manager.
Every opportunity that came along,
he said yes to because he was trying
to build a career to send
three kids to college.
But every one of these --
Every one of these moves --
Every one of these
promotions involved a move.
And so we moved around in Iowa
several times, moved to Illinois,
to Missouri, to Oklahoma, to Kansas,
and that was all before ninth grade.
So every two years I would
be the new kid in school.
And if you've ever been the new
kid in school you know how brutal
that can be, how kind of
isolating and lonely that can feel.
So that's what I gave to
Samuel, the abandoned kid.
Like this kind of sense of
isolation and loneliness, you know,
that I felt in those moments.
So then, you know, so you
have all these things in play.
And you're like, "Well,
how do they all connect?"
And I realized maybe six or
seven years in to the process --
I realized that they all
connected because they're all ways
where first people have sort
of walled themselves off
in their own world, and second,
ways in which people have lost
the ability to communicate
with people outside of that world.
So it's -- I think this is
true for people who are --
certain people who are totally
committed to political ideologies,
to gamers, to people obsessed
with their social image status,
to people obsessed with
their devices or even people
in relationships who for one
reason or another grow apart,
stop communicating, and suddenly
seem like strangers to each other.
So I realized that this was a
novel actually about isolation,
about disconnection,
about living in a bubble
of your own mind's creation.
So I realized this wasn't
actually a protest novel,
but rather the protest stuff
was just a kind of backdrop
for what was actually
happening with my characters.
That it was more like a
baseline instead of the melody.
And that's why revision is
so important because then
after nine years of doing this I
got to go back and make it seem
like I intended to
do that all along.
And so the neat thing that
happens is about -- This --
You know, this far in to the
process suddenly you begin
to understand what you're doing.
And you get to be intentional where
before you were maybe instinctive.
So if this is a novel about our
inability to see each other,
listen to each other,
how do I capture
that on a smaller scale,
on a human scale?
It would be pretty boring if I
just wrote about kind of democrats
and republicans fighting.
How can I make that personal?
So I wanted just to read you
the prologue from the novel.
With these ideas in mind about
how people can kind of grow
to live inside their own heads,
their own private worlds,
and how even people who live
together can be total mysteries
to each other.
"If Samuel had known
his mother was leaving,
he might have paid more attention.
He might have listened
more carefully to her,
observed her more closely, written
certain crucial things down.
Maybe he could have
acted differently,
spoken differently,
been a different person.
Maybe he could have been a
child worth sticking around for.
But Samuel did not know
his mother was leaving.
He did not know she had been
leaving for many months now,
in secret, and in pieces.
She had been removing items
from the house one by one.
A single dress from her closet.
Then a lone photo from the album.
A fork from the silverware drawer.
A quilt from under the bed.
Every week she took something new.
A sweater.
A pair of shoes.
A Christmas ornament.
A book. Slowly her presence
in the house grew thinner.
She'd been at it almost a year
when Samuel and his father began
to sense something, a sort
of instability, a puzzling
and disturbing, and sometimes even
sinister feeling of depletion.
It struck them at odd moments.
They looked at the
bookshelf and thought,
'Don't we own more books than that?'
They walked by the china cabinet
and felt sure something
was missing, but what?
They could not give it
a name, this impression
that life's details
were being reorganized.
They didn't understand that the
reason they were no longer eating
Crock-Pot meals was that
the Crock-Pot was no longer
in the house.
If the bookshelf seemed bare,
it was because she had
pruned it of its poetry.
If the china cabinet seemed a little
vacant, it was because two plates,
two bowls, and a teapot had
been lifted from the collection.
They were being burglarized
at a very slow pace.
'Didn't there used to be
more photos on that wall?'
Samuel's father said, standing at
the foot of the stairs, squinting.
'Didn't we have that picture
from the Grand Canyon up there?'
'No,' Samuel's mother said.
'We put that picture away.'
'We did? I don't remember that.'
'It was your decision.'
'It was?' he said, befuddled.
He thought he was losing his mind.
Years later in a high school
biology class Samuel heard a story
about a certain kind of African
turtle that swam across the ocean
to lay its eggs in South America.
Scientists could find no
reason for the enormous trip.
Why did the turtles do it?
The leading theory was that
they began doing it eons ago
when South America and Africa
were still locked together.
Back then only a river might
have separated the continents,
and the turtles lay their
eggs on the river's far bank.
But then the continents
began drifting apart,
and the river widened by
about an inch per year
which would have been
invisible to the turtles.
So they kept going to the same
spot, the far bank of the river,
each generation swimming a tiny
bit farther than the last one.
And after 100 million years of
this the river had become an ocean,
and yet the turtles never noticed.
This, Samuel decided, was the
manner of his mother's departure.
This was how she moved away.
Imperceptibly.
Slowly. Bit by bit.
She whittled down her life
until the only thing left
to remove was herself.
On the day she disappeared, she left
the house with a single suitcase."
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
Thank you very much.
I would be happy to answer any --
I think we might have
about 10 minutes to go.
I would be happy to answer any
questions that anybody has.
I think there are two mics,
one there and one there,
if you have something
you want to talk about.
>> Speaker 2: Hi.
>> Nathan Hill: Hi there.
>> Speaker 2: I loved your book.
I think I read it in one night.
>> Nathan Hill: Wow.
>> Speaker 2: It was that good.
>> Nathan Hill: It's a long book.
>> Speaker 2: I know.
And I just want to ask if you
have any connection to Norway
and why the Norwegian folk stories.
>> Nathan Hill: Yeah.
Thank you.
The nix of the title is a
story from Norwegian folklore.
A nix also has many different
names, depending on where you are.
It's called a nix or a [inaudible]
or a neck or [inaudible] but yeah.
It comes from Norwegian folklore,
and my mother's family came here
from Norway several generations ago.
They moved first to a
small town in Minnesota,
and then after a time moved to
eastern Iowa, to a town on the banks
of the Mississippi river.
And that's where most of
my family still lives.
Farmers. And we didn't know anything
about the family back in Norway,
like it all got -- As soon
as I think it was my great,
great grandfather came
over, all ties were severed.
But my mom remembers her grandmother
saying that he came from Hammerfest
which didn't mean anything to
me until I finally Googled it
and found it was the
northernmost city in the world.
I'm just like, "That's amazing."
You know? And no wonder he found
Minnesota familiar, you know.
And so when I started writing in
"The Nix" I had this character,
Faye's father, who
immigrates from Norway.
And it was sort of
an opportunity for me
to give myself a family history that
I didn't know, that we don't know.
To fill in some blanks,
I guess I should say.
And so, you know, Hammerfest
has this extraordinary history.
Especially what happened to it
after World War II is just amazing.
And so I decided to kind of
use a lot of that information.
And of course the folktales that
have always kind of stuck with me
because I know they're
part of my own history.
Thank you.
Hi there.
>> Speaker 3: Hi.
I also really enjoyed your book.
And one of the many
things that struck me
about it was you had this one
chapter where there's kind
of a regular sentence,
and then the rest
of the chapter is all one sentence.
And, believe it or not, you know,
it really it works beautifully.
But I'm curious about that.
I'm curious like was it
always like that one sentence
or were you showing off or were you
ever accused of showing off or --
>> Nathan Hill: Oh, yeah.
>> Speaker 3: It's
an amazing sentence.
>> Nathan Hill: Yeah.
Look what I can do.
Yeah. No. Thanks.
I'm glad it worked.
I -- So yeah.
It's a chapter late in the book and
there's a character in the book.
You never know his real name.
You only know his avatar's name, his
video game avatar, which is Pwnage.
And Pwnage is hopelessly recklessly
addicted to this video game called
"World of Elfscape" which is
really just "World of Warcraft,"
but I didn't want to be
beholden to Warcraft fans
who are very knowledgeable
on this subject.
So I made up my own video game.
And for certain reasons he's decided
he needs to quit this video game,
but like I was talking about
earlier, you know, like in some ways
when you're really in to these
games there's a sense of --
Your sense of, what, self esteem,
your sense of meaning in the world,
can be constructed or maybe I
should say fulfilled by a game.
And so he's a guy whose
relationship is in shambles,
whose job is in shambles.
Nothing is going right for him
except being an epic player
at this game, and then I'm
like, "What is going to happen
when he decides to
give up his one outlet
for like meaning and creativity?"
And so yeah.
I was writing it and I
was writing in a notebook,
and the first sentence
for this chapter is,
"Today was the day he was
going to give up video games."
And then I started listing
when I was writing it,
like the first draft.
I'd do everything handwritten.
I was just doing a list,
like kind of bullets.
And I just tried to think
of every excuse in the book
as to why he could not
possibly give up video games.
Every excuse that he
would give himself,
every way to justify this behavior.
And I was reading it to my wife,
and it was in no syntactic
order or anything.
It was just a list.
And eventually she was like,
"Is this all one sentence?"
I was like, "No.
It's a list."
But that kind of stuck
with me, and I'm like,
"Maybe I could do it
as one sentence."
And I got to thinking
like, "Oh, my god.
Like if there's a way
I could embody this --
his sense of the world coming --
kind of closing down around him,
his sense of claustrophobia,
his sense of terror at what he's
about to do, maybe if -- I
could do that syntactically."
And just make this huge
edifice of a sentence,
this 10 page sentence,
grammatically correct.
This 10 page sentence.
And maybe the reader would
feel the kind of anxiety
that my character was feeling.
So I thought there
was an emotional kind
of character driven reason to do it.
So I did it.
And that's when I needed
for the first time ever
in my writing career a spreadsheet
because I had to like figure out --
Like I was nesting clauses within
clauses within clauses to try
to make all of this work out.
And so yeah.
It took a long time
to do it, but yeah.
And I was certain that an editor or
publisher would want me to cut it.
But then my editor said it was
actually his favorite chapter
in the book.
He called it the guitar solo
from "Bohemian Rhapsody."
I was like, "Awesome.
All right."
Thank you.
I think we have time for one more.
>> Speaker 4: Hi.
So a lot of your characters seem to
have an undiagnosed social anxiety,
and I guess I don't
really have a question.
What does that mean to you?
Why are so many of your
characters so anxious
about being around other people?
>> Nathan Hill: You don't know this.
This is all terrifying
me right now [laughs].
No. Like I was talking about
earlier, like when you realize
that you're writing a book about
isolation, about disconnection,
you start looking for
ways to do that.
And, you know, I don't have any
kind of social anxiety disorder,
but I'm nervous around new people.
I want to make a good impression.
And I'm an introvert, and so like
you kind of use those things.
You know? And kind of push them a
little bit, or a lot, in some cases.
Right? So yeah.
I guess you take the parts of
yourself, especially the moments
when you felt this the
most, like when I'm trying
to impress someone who's
really important, you know.
I don't know.
A woman that I'm interested
in or a -- I don't know.
A boss that I want a
job from or something.
You know? You take how weird
you feel in those moments,
and then you just -- And
then you kind of wrap
that around the character.
What if that character felt
that emotion all the time?
You know? I thought it was just
a way to kind of amp up the theme
of the book, this sense
of like growing isolation,
this growing disconnection.
And I was hoping that with the
video games and the social anxiety
and the cell phones
and the politics,
all of these things would kind of
[inaudible] together into a book
that hopefully kind of made sense.
And even though these things aren't
kind of logically tied together,
they're emotionally tied together.
And so you would feel
this thing coming at you
from various different vectors.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, everybody.
It's been a pleasure.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Speaker 1: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.